now we found this clip and this is gonna
blow your mind okay
you may remember a uh a guy by the name
of david letterman he was a late night
host for about 30 years he used to make
jokes about all sorts of stuff and he'd
make fun of all sorts of people and i
loved love love david letterman and i
wish i know he's got some interview show
now but i wish that show continued
nobody really watches late night shows
anymore but we needed somebody that was
not purely political right you didn't
know his politics it was a little more
like johnny carson you didn't know
exactly what he thought he kind of made
fun of everybody well he had a couple
years ago
he had this woman on and her name is
serena williams and serena williams is
the best female tennis player on earth
in the history of the world she's the
best ain't no doubt about it well she
went on letterman's show a couple years
ago and you're not going to believe this
the bigot that she is she said there's
biological differences between men and
women wow
actually it's funny because andy murray
he oh he was been joking about um myself
and him playing a match and i'm like
andy seriously like are you kidding me
because for me tennis in men's tennis
and women's centers are completely
almost two separate sports so i'm like
if i were to play andy murray i would
lose 6060 in
five to six minutes maybe 10 minutes
because
no it's true it's a completely
it's a completely different word the men
are a lot faster and me and um they they
get they serve harder they hit hard it's
just a different game and i love to play
women's students and i i only want to
play girls because i don't want to be
embarrassed i would not do the tour i
wouldn't do billie jean any justice so
andy stop it we're not i'm not gonna let
you kill me i'm with you when it comes
to tennis i only wanna play girls
letterman making a joke about how he
wants to play against girls in tennis
to a girl tennis player
i mean really think about that right now
did you guys know this right at this
very moment tucker carlson who has the
highest rated show in the history of
cable news he has been banned from
twitter for the last six days or so
because he made a point saying that leah
thomas the the swimmer the biologically
male swimmer who's winning all the
female tournaments uh basically
shouldn't be winning all the female
tournaments he's now been banned from
twitter highest
rated cable news host in the history of
television he's gone from twitter for
basically just saying exactly what
serena williams female tennis star
serena williams is saying right there
men are stronger they hit the ball
harder as a general rule they surf
faster not only that she's saying
they're completely different sports
they're completely different sports and
that andy murray would beat her
basically 606 0 in a couple minutes is
that because she's a bigot is that
because serena williams is self-hating
or hates women or something like that
do you think that's what it is